talking about dribbling yeah but they
got the mismatch therefore each side
dodge X with the left hand block the
advantage inside would be SJ and those
two doctors good downs hitch handling
into the frontcourt for the Mavericks
behind the back dribble to the rim and
all would have finished
born and raised outside North America
date is Dusen as an assistant in the NBA
the last 18 years da yet another great
pass to the Andre Jordan that's going to
be a talent to watch this year on the
Beatrice today Minka Jordan
so it's going to be fun Curley deals get
out look at that it's a good one
you faked me out no player likes to look
where the ball is dogs hit in the
backboard
picked up by Lucas seven seconds as he
crosses half-court plenty of times
weren't decline inside pops it up in the
round that it goes into the foul just
dribbling it
everybody's watching they step back
three Luca hits it when you need a
basket that my friends is a good place
to go
the finish hit the open for Luca chance
and a foul again
[Applause]
they gave it to him
gave it to her and closed it the second
quart out the way they did they're going
to be in control eight for forestry
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
then here's all skill Luca on the end
smoke the three off the front rim kept
alive by clima it's marShon Brooks
Brooks loses the ball on the way up
and now you've got me Andre Jordan all
alone and slants at all and towards the
Indiana trip in January of those
mastered a jam by cleaver
well last minute take a look so you made
the cut Luka with the supreme vision for
the jam step-back three
deandre will rip it out of the post and
Luke is gonna have to take the step back
three goes under kind of read to go for
a vacant looka three shot attempts that
he took in the nineteen minutes that he
played against Brooklyn on Wednesday max
lost it Luca got it back he turned 21
years old on Sunday Dennis Smith jr. TN
the ball on the right side fed it to
DeAndre through traffic went to the
corner same spot where Luca made one
you said it the matador the harder it is
the easier he makes it look a little
step-back that time nothing but cool
[Applause]
[Music]
look at me your love right now group is
going bananas down there right now heart
but why shoot around the leg turning out
a lot ofits right now defensive very
alertly guarding LeBron James on the
knees LeBron didn't Syd the first time
with the second time spit driving it on
Lilly then it's got 5,000 Smith's left
he found Luca
[Applause]
great step back three Smith lost his
footing and then here's Luke de harf
this tremendous ability to stay on
balance after stepping back
to have the strength to get that shot up
that's not necessarily an easy shot it's
just a great offensive place
[Music]
Lucca averages seven pull-up jump shots
per game and shoots 41% now that may not
sound like a lot us have made them work
for this one
that's what you want to do getting
looked off right here
[Applause]
one to the finish it's a great dog
excellent pass from Luca
[Applause]
[Music]
Lucan can fall in love with that three
ball all day long cuddled ari got picked
off gotcha
oh nice step back ten five gets the
frame okay dark church Jonas Jerebko
went into the game and Luca goes right
at work now that ducks again it's strong
it is pick and choose indeed
[Applause]
this guy has superstar written all over
him
[Applause]
that is Matt Luca late clock
something interesting is about to happen
into the shot clock bang I got nothing
behind the back and then the step back
to the right kidding to Dallas at 14 and
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna do it on my own right here
late clock situation outside the spit
lines Luke of Westbrook up on e into the
shot clock
pump Bay yes sir
deep freeze while we baked it in
[Applause]
The Legend of Luca continuing to be
written for the rookie smart toppling
off as he contested that was clearly a
foul
dodging Buffy should have gotten the
three hands one
[Music]
stay tuned service their little reason
went to Washington Jordans screening
Luca Luca magic on display early on he's
got a chance for his first four-point
play that step back his special things
you worry Luca brings the walk up the
floor what's he gonna do off the screen
set by Jordan one minute
[Applause]
from Oregon second-year player Jordan
bill going in draymond Green is out Lake
block here it is to step back accept
Luca magic on a three-pointer unless you
let it was that's the wide open forcing
him to be the shooter get cut right here
[Applause]
one second differential will it very
well Mike stay tuned for the next couple
of seconds a
[Applause]
[Music]
stupids habit
keep going to the fourth there is Luca
we have seen it and Rudy Gaye can live
there I'm even hurt some but like it at
the great finish that time by Luca he
practices that stuff it's a possibility
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
fast break takes all
Center sit offense Hartwell defense top
this is what you want when you're facing
one of the top teams in the Eastern
Conference don't look now here come the
logo Barnes draws the defense touch pass
by Matthews Luke at the end of the shot
clock got it back with Dennis it's gonna
come back to and look through are you
ready see what he's going to do three
seconds crosses half-court they tried to
stop it they cut right to the top with
an exclamation point on a heck of a
first tab right around the defense so
chance
looka these four dollars with 28 points
if fictional force happens he is
literally carrying things he's walked
down the five flavors he's brought along
water backs
things happen
[Applause]
this is all Luka here just attack it in
the open court showing off that
tremendous skill
as the player has really gotten better
at the start the game
they said that for each month they
switch right in the middle estranged um
that is so weird
vans blankets Harrison have taken a 36
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
flipz luca against Austin Rivers break
it down towards a minute to play in the
first quarter with your player from
Colorado half-court heat center court
big shot
beyond half-court even that's a good
finish by Luther closing out the second
quarter
Mavericks need to regroup in a bad way
well if you're looking for a lifeline
maybe that's one shooting off the bounce
to so far this contest
you can't Eric Gordon he's fouled and he
got it to go back to the right hand T
points hit rebounds for equal of Gucci
[ __ ] deep inside Luca
[Music]
shredder said that gets
[Applause]
[Music]
that's it deepest tribes are no cell
functions of the watch ticks is download
touch 20 to 20 in one and here's Luka
with the up up one more time let me give
it to you like Kevin McHale used to give
it to us
[Applause]
[Music]
Dallas it's got the lead dodge it throws
down a sledgehammer don't sling foam
Luka literally had the mismatch you
thought I was gonna land up now I'm
flashing it on you decision was on the
body down low
bobble pass by Yusuf Newark itch oh that
was an interesting version of ball don't
why Dallas got it back up the turnover
and looked on the run-out slam next to
Cleveland's come on Dirk's gone out and
Luka deflects the inbounds pass it it's
picked up by Jalen Brunson Brunson to
Justin Jackson looked away the defensive
bound just a Jackson in transition we
had him in Dallas obviously pretty
steady look we're minute look at three
for three Retief to start the game it is
the Dirk and Lucas show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
seven years old he's certainly going out
as harp said earlier still playing very
well the song white sights given moment
ago for Miami and us across court past
and Brian broke off 14 of his last 20
Jalen wait fear Luca from Bronson yes
sir splashdown 3 over Derrick - its
tuner and for the year by the way he
averages a little bit over three assists
so passing is in his repertoire it's in
Luke Adonis repertoire as well but no
need to pass when you're able to just
knife right through the defense doing
the damage when it comes to scoring
tonight Luke in 2016
[Applause]
Dierks got back guillotine tongues and
there's also been a foul call as well
[Applause]
that's good presence to get that shot up
focus knocked it down was it up in time
I see the amber light on the backboard
I think they should let Dirk review this
video what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content